I want you to meet this gentleman Richard Richard
is from Hollywood where he's a producer in the
movie and music business say hi to Richard hey
Richard what's up hey how you doing Howard how
you doing Cathy yeah hi love your story and
I I love you know I just I love your attitude
and that's what I fell in love with Richard wants
everyone to know he has a great sense of humor he
produced a music CD called pull my finger it was
comprised entirely of fart sounds in fact let me
play a clip this is a hit called silent but deadly
night what was this this was a farting I think two
silent right yeah yeah Christmas songs wait he was
farting no who farted on this record Richard well
we have we had over uh 10 people create farts for
this real actual farts um we made a documentary
of it at pullmyfinger.com you can see a free
documentary all right let me play it [Music]
hmm fabulous I'll go out with you [Laughter]
when you were making this anyone [__] their
pants yeah yes yeah that is covered in the
dock but yes wow and you use some of your own
farts right you saw my own farts react and we
actually secretly put uh microphones inside of
a toilet bowl when people were taking crabs we
would actually perhaps Cathy just actually walked
with Cathy you're a little turned off to this uh
it's not my thing like bathroom type stuff and
farting you're a fan of this show I love this
show I love it listening to the show it was 20
years ago the guy's matured and by the way I'll
let you brag a little bit Richard how big is
your penis oh oh how many inches of seven and
seven inches yeah a nice size Cathy writing it
down I think that's important Cathy I'm curious
what did you just write down I see you John I
literally wrote seven inches as if I forget it
foreign